foreign
ER in Fort Wayne Indiana hi Haley how
are you
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
I was just wondering if we should pay
off our car with the profit from our
home sale
why wouldn't you
um because where we don't have
anywhere like we're going to be living
with his mom
um
saving for a while there's no end date
to living with her
um
she wants there to be an end date how
long have you been married I do
um eight years
so what is the profits from the home
sale
um it should be from 50 to 58 Grand
maybe okay and why why'd you sell your
house
basically because we can't afford it
okay and how much is your car debt
it's around 16 000. and what's your
household income
he makes around 58 000 a year okay and
you have three kids
two kids two kids okay do you work
outside the home Haley no I do not okay
so if you were to pay off your car uh
that that would leave you forty thousand
dollars forty two thousand dollars to be
precise correct
okay and you if you went and rented a
house
why do you have to live with your
mother-in-law what you do wrong
basically
he just wants to live mortgage free like
he want he thinks that I don't care what
he wants I'm asking what you guys did
wrong I mean
you're like grown-up adults with a sixty
thousand dollar job and two kids and you
have no debt and forty two thousand
dollars in the bank you should not have
to live with your mother-in-law
well it'd be really hard to buy a house
I said go rent that's options
yeah he hasn't thought about that at all
I mean it sounds like a waste of money
basically
I don't know so is a divorce
yeah
no they ain't living with my
mother-in-law Haley with no ending this
is our fourth time so yeah your fourth
time living with her
yeah why has this become the hammock why
is this for your life why is this a
pattern I don't know the thing is his
mom has said that she would give us two
acres oh that's sweet I don't know I'm
living with my mother-in-law
um two acres is not enough room
of like somehow being able to build like
a barndominium but now we're at the
point where he's like well maybe we can
afford like an apartment with a garage
on it which I've been trying to be open
to but having two young kids I'm like
yeah it sounds like kind of small I
think your husband needs to choose
reality and the reality is we can't
afford the dream Barn dominium we have
to rent for a while while we keep saving
yeah listen mom's not the answer to your
future Prosperity you and your husband
developing a game plan is the answer to
your future Prosperity every time we run
home to her for future Prosperity your
life gets worse not better
okay did I miss something
no no please go read something
inexpensively take five jobs you pick up
a side job that you can do from home
while the kids are there you guys get to
work make some more money pile up some
money to add to the 42 and go get you a
nice little house that you can afford
quit running home to Mama you're too old
what I would do